Hi, Josh and Craig.
嗨，Josh 和 Craig。
My name is Michaela and I have been watching him for nine years because of my beautiful girlfriend, Karmina.
我叫 Michaela，因为我漂亮的女朋友 Karmina，我已经看这部剧九年了。
Before meeting her, I hadn't seen the show at all.
在遇到她之前，我根本没看过这部剧。
I had no idea what it was about and honestly at first, I thought it was a little bit difficult to watch, mainly with the Barney character being so horrifying to women.
我完全不知道它讲的是什么，老实说，起初我觉得有点看不下去，主要是因为 Barney 这个角色对女性来说太可怕了。
But over the years I've grown to love Eva Barney and the show and it's a regular everyday part of our lives and we watch it quite literally every single day.
但这些年来，我开始喜欢上 Eva Barney 和这部剧，它已经成为我们日常生活中不可或缺的一部分，我们几乎每天都在看。
I really resonate with Ted because he blurted out, I love you so quickly and I think I blur it out.
我真的很有共鸣，因为 Ted 脱口而出“我爱你”，而我想我也脱口而出了。
I love you to her on our third or fifth date or something.
我在第三次或第五次约会时就对她说“我爱你”之类的。
I also wanted to give a little shout out to Josh's wife, being a therapist.
我还想顺便提一下 Josh 的妻子，她是一位治疗师。
She's so cool.
她太酷了。
I love hearing her takes on how I met your mother because they are just so, so interesting.
我喜欢听她对《老爸老妈浪漫史》的看法，因为它们真的非常、非常有意思。
And I'm also a therapist, so it's nice to hear that perspective too.
我也是一名治疗师，所以听到那个视角也很好。
Yeah.
是的。
And I wanted to say to Carmina, you're good looking, you're funny, you're smart.
我想对 Karmina 说，你长得好看，又幽默，又聪明。
Now would you frickin marry me already?
现在，你能不能该死地嫁给我了？
I'm a low EI won't be soon In New York City When I see you Please permit me To tell you everything In New York City Well hello and welcome to another episode of How We Made Your Mother I'm Josh Radner I'm joined by my friend Craig Thomas Hey Craig Hey Josh We are making our way through How I Met Your Mother A series that we collaborated on for many years.
我是一个低 EI，不会很快在纽约市，当我见到你，请允许我告诉你一切，在纽约市，嗯，你好，欢迎收看《How We Made Your Mother》的另一集，我是 Josh Radner，我的朋友 Craig Thomas 也加入了，嘿 Craig，嘿 Josh，我们正在重温《老爸老妈浪漫史》，这是一部我们合作多年的系列剧。
Years ago, I played Ted Mosby on that show.
多年前，我在那部剧中饰演 Ted Mosby。
Craig co-created the show with Carter Bayes.
Craig 和 Carter Bayes 共同创作了这部剧。
But we're also making history on the pod today because I believe that was our first marriage proposal on the podcast, right?
但我们今天也在播客中创造了历史，因为我相信这是我们播客中的第一次求婚，对吧？
That was a marriage proposal on the podcast.
那确实是播客中的一次求婚。
And that's what just happened.
刚才发生的就是那样。
That's just how we're waiting.
我们就是这样等待的。
How are we going to know?
我们要怎么知道呢？
I know.
我知道。
How will we know?
我们要怎么知道？
And also, like, when does this air versus when do we go?
而且，这集什么时候播出，我们什么时候录制？
Like, we're way ahead of the story.
我们比故事进度领先太多了。
Like we know this is a strange thing.
我们知道这很奇怪。
We know way more longer than Karmina will know this.
我们知道的时间比 Karmina 知道的时间要长得多。
Karmina, we're gonna be sitting on this for like a month and a half.
Karmina，我们要为这件事保密一个半月左右。
I don't know how we're gonna keep it to ourselves.
我不知道我们要怎么守口如瓶。
But we hope that was a great way to receive a marriage proposal, we're thrilled.
但我们希望那是一种很棒的求婚方式，我们很激动。
Thank you.
谢谢。
When you please tell us what happens, you gotta follow us.
当你请告诉我们发生了什么时，你得关注我们。
We need a follow up.
我们需要后续报道。
We need visuals and videos.
我们需要视觉资料和视频。
We need, we will accept our wedding invitations, whatever you wanna put them in the mail.
我们需要，我们会接受你们的婚礼请柬，无论你们想怎么寄给我们。
Yeah, and a video of her hearing that would be terrific.
是的，如果能有她听到求婚时的视频就太棒了。
Anyway, well, we often have very special episodes of How We Made Your Mother, but today, very, very special episode of How We Made Your Mother.
总之，我们经常有非常特别的《How We Made Your Mother》剧集，但今天，是《How We Made Your Mother》非常、非常特别的一集。
Oh, yes.
哦，是的。
Oh, yes, very special guest.
哦，是的，非常特别的嘉宾。
I don't know how you're gonna top this special guest.
我不知道你要怎么超越这位特别嘉宾。
It started with a proposal.
它以求婚开始。
It's all downhill from here, but we have one of the greats.
从这里开始就走下坡路了，但我们请到了一位大人物。
And I'll introduce this gentleman because he was one of the earliest believers in How I Met Your Mother.
我要介绍这位先生，因为他是《老爸老妈浪漫史》最早的信徒之一。
He was on the pilot with Carter and I.
他和 Carter 以及我一起参与了试播集。
He's a wonderful writer, a wonderful director.
他是一位出色的编剧，一位出色的导演。
he directed the episode we're gonna be talking about today too.
他今天也执导了我们要讨论的那一集。
Ladies and gentlemen, one of my best friends, Rob Greenberg.
女士们先生们，我最好的朋友之一，Rob Greenberg。
Rob.
Rob。
Josh, I cray, I see you.
Josh，Craig，见到你们很高兴。
Thanks for having me, I'm delighted to be here.
谢谢你们邀请我，我很高兴能来到这里。
Yeah.
是的。
Sorry, all the thunder was stolen by the one in the marriage proposal.
抱歉，所有的风头都被那个求婚抢走了。
But she did say marry me already.
但她确实说了“该死地嫁给我吧”。
So I don't know if it's the first time to talk.
所以我不知道这是否是第一次谈论。
You're gonna parse this now, you're gonna ruin this moment?
你现在要分析这个吗，你要毁掉这个时刻吗？
That's why you brought me down.
这就是你叫我来的原因吗。
The third time's a charm, yeah.
事不过三，是的。
Rob, now when I met Carter, Craig, and Pam in that room, on that rainy day, 20 some years ago, I also met you that day.
Rob，当我 20 多年前在那个下雨天在那个房间里见到 Carter、Craig 和 Pam 时，我也在那天见到了你。
You were in that room at those original auditions and as we have established with the lore that I was the very first person you guys saw on the very first date.
你在那些最初的试镜房间里，正如我们根据传说所确定的那样，我是你们在第一天见到的第一个人。
Do you have a lot of strong memories of that?
你对那件事有很深刻的记忆吗？
I do, I do.
我有，我有。
I said, look, I'm not a fan.
我说，看，我不是粉丝。
I was very vocal.
我当时表达得很直白。
You were kind for him.
你对他很客气。
I was all in like everybody else.
我和其他人一样，完全投入了。
Yes, I was there, I was there that day.
是的，我在那里，那天我在那里。
But were you, I mean, Craig, this might be a question for you too, but were you like assigned as the adult for these young preschoolers who had their first TV show on here?
但是，Craig，这可能也是问你的问题，你们当时是被指派作为这些第一次做电视剧的年轻学龄前儿童的成年人吗？
Oh, yes.
哦，是的。
They needed an adult.
他们需要一个成年人。
Yeah.
是的。
And somehow I was on the list and we met and hit it off and yes.
不知何故我在名单上，我们见面并一拍即合，是的。
Yeah.
是的。
And can you give us a little bit of your background in television?
你能给我们介绍一下你的电视背景吗？
I know you came from, you were on Frasier for many years.
我知道你来自，你在《欢乐一家亲》工作了很多年。
Is that right?
是这样吗？
I was on Frasier for many years.
我在《欢乐一家亲》工作了很多年。
I did a bunch of pilots and I, I don't know, I guess I was directing and writing and various shows.
我做了很多试播集，我不知道，我想我是在各种节目中担任导演和编剧。
Yes.
是的。
Yeah.
I think I was on, I was on an overall deal at Warner Brothers.
我想我当时在华纳兄弟有一份全面协议。
Yeah, you were not under a deal.
是的，你当时没有协议。
You were not under a deal at 20.
你在 20 岁时没有协议。
We met a coral tree on San Vicente.
我们在 San Vicente 的 Coral Tree 见面。
We did.
我们确实见面了。
That was our meet cute.
那是我们的初次邂逅。
We had our meet to you at a cute little cafe on San Vicente in front wood, which you are a specialist in making sure people come very close to where you live.
我们在 Brentwood San Vicente 的一家可爱的小咖啡馆里见面，你很擅长确保人们来到离你住处很近的地方。
do not like.
我不喜欢。
I just had done it with Rob a few weeks ago in LA and it was two minutes from his house.
几周前我在洛杉矶刚和 Rob 做过这件事，离他家只有两分钟路程。
And Rob, you, I mean, you had us beat by having ever worked on a multi-camera sitcom, which Carter and I had not.
Rob，你的意思是，你比我们更有优势，因为你曾经做过多机位情景喜剧，而 Carter 和我没有。
And I think basically the studio looked at these two 30 year old guys who we looked five.
我想基本上制片厂看着这两个 30 岁的家伙，我们看起来像 5 岁。
You were 29.
你当时 29 岁。
You looked so young, I know.
你们看起来太年轻了，我知道。
And we, and They said, we need an adult and Frasier was a huge hit, and everyone loves you anyway.
他们说，我们需要一个成年人，《欢乐一家亲》是一个巨大的成功，而且无论如何每个人都喜欢你。
And they said, Rob, and we met a few different people, if I'm being honest, but we didn't, we loved you, we fell in love.
他们说，Rob，老实说，我们见过几个不同的人，但我们没有，我们喜欢你，我们爱上了你。
It was a click, and just the same way that it was with Pam.
那是一种默契，就像和 Pam 一样。
It was just like, again, we just found all the right, perfect people very early on.
就像，我们很早就找到了所有合适、完美的人。
It was really- Did you meet with more people after you met with me, or before you met with me?
这真的——你在见到我之后，还是在见到我之前，又见了更多人吗？
We got a lot of nose and then we doubled back to you.
我们聊了很多，然后又转回了你这里。
Okay, all right, all right.
好的，行，没问题。
Rob, can you, if you can cast your memory back that far, Like, do you remember reading the pilot and what your first impressions were and also what you thought when you met Craig and Carter?
罗伯，如果你还能回忆起那么久以前的事，你还记得读试播集时的第一印象吗？还有你见到克雷格和卡特时是怎么想的？
I, you know, the truth is I don't think a lot about it.
你知道，说实话，我没怎么多想。
I kind of shoot from my gut.
我这人做事比较凭直觉。
I read the script and I liked it and I met Carter and Craig and I liked them and I was in.
我读了剧本，觉得不错，见了卡特和克雷格，也觉得他们很好，我就加入了。
Yeah.
没错。
That was it.
就是这样。
I didn't read it five times.
我没有读过五遍。
They analyzed it.
他们分析过。
I didn't do any of that.
我可没做过那些。
It's very strange behavior from a Jewish man to not overthink things, but this is why we love you.
作为一个犹太人，不把事情想得太复杂，这行为真的很奇怪，但这就是我们爱你的原因。
Exactly.
没错。
it felt very easy that way.
那样感觉很轻松。
And I said, no to a lot of things.
而且我拒绝过很多东西。
So it was this one I liked.
所以这一部我是真的喜欢。
Yeah.
是啊。
Well, you were a good believer in what was special about it.
嗯，你确实很相信它的独特之处。
And you always said, don't let them, don't let notes make you whittle down, sand away the edges of what makes a special.
你总是说，别让那些意见让你削减内容，别磨掉那些让它变得特别的棱角。
You said, go down, swing in, keep this special, keep this interesting, keep the storytelling unique and singular.
你说，要深入挖掘，要大胆尝试，保持它的独特性，保持它的趣味性，让叙事保持独特和唯一。
And you really helped us in that way, Rob, because we were so new, We had never gone through the pilot process.
罗伯，你在那方面真的帮了我们很多，因为我们当时太新了，从来没经历过试播集的过程。
Well, I've been through many pilot process on my own and my friends, and you can see it get derailed during the process, and my job was not to let you get it derailed.
嗯，我自己和朋友们经历过很多次试播集过程，你能看到它在过程中偏离轨道，而我的工作就是不让你们偏离轨道。
But isn't it funny that the studio ostensibly assigned you to kind of keep them, you know, playing by the company rules, but you were actually like, don't listen to these people.
但很有趣不是吗？制片厂表面上指派你来监督他们，让他们按公司的规矩办事，但你实际上却在说，别听这些人的。
Yeah, I mean, nothing if not subversive.
是啊，我这人别的没有，就是有点反叛。
Yeah, you really were.
你确实是。
Sure.
当然。
And you were on with us many, many years in the writer's room mostly, but in season two, you started also directing.
你和我们一起工作了很多很多年，大部分时间是在编剧室，但在第二季，你也开始执导了。
You were in the room on and off for all of those years.
那些年里，你断断续续一直都在编剧室。
And how many years were you on the show, total?
你总共在这个剧组待了多少年？
I was on, I was consulting for six years.
我担任顾问六年。
Six years.
六年。
And then you would still direct now and again, even after you left consulting.
而且即使在你不再担任顾问后，你偶尔还是会回来执导。
Yes.
是的。
You're the only other director of how much a mother that really directed a solid handful or two of episodes besides Pam Fryman.
除了帕姆·弗莱曼，你是《老爸老妈浪漫史》中唯一一位真正执导过一两手之数剧集的导演。
Do you want to talk about, like, in season two, you started to direct episodes.
你想聊聊第二季你开始执导剧集的事吗？
I think Monday Night Football was maybe your second or third, the first one that you tagged in literally because Pam got sick one week.
我想《周一橄榄球之夜》可能是你执导的第二或第三集，那是你第一次临时顶上，因为帕姆那周生病了。
And the entire nine years that never happened, but our in-house director got sick and like just had to go home on like a Tuesday, right?
在整整九年里，这种情况从未发生过，但我们的内部导演生病了，周二那天不得不回家，对吧？
And the day before we were starting to shoot and you literally like stepped in for you went down from the writer's room, Tagged and took the baton and just started directing the episode.
就在我们开拍的前一天，你直接从编剧室下来，接过了指挥棒，就开始执导那一集了。
That was your auspicious first one.
那是你吉祥的处女作。
I forget what episode that was.
我忘了那是哪一集了。
Until I know what little the director does.
直到我知道导演要做什么。
It's a little, well, well, well, well, well, well machine.
这就像一台运转良好的机器。
Everyone knows what they're doing.
每个人都知道自己在做什么。
Just get out of the way and make sure it doesn't go off the rail.
只要别挡路，确保它不脱轨就行。
Which one was that, Rob?
那是哪一集，罗伯？
Was that like the second episode of season two?
是第二季的第二集吗？
Like, scorpion on the toad?
比如《蝎子与蟾蜍》？
Maybe?
也许吧？
Was it the end of the toad?
是《蟾蜍的终结》吗？
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
对，对，对。
I did scorpion on the toad.
我执导了《蝎子与蟾蜍》。
I did columns, and then I did this one on the first episode.
我执导了《专栏》，然后执导了这一集，这是第一集。
So you did two in a row.
所以你连续执导了两集。
So columns in this one were back to back?
所以《专栏》和这一集是背靠背播出的？
They were back to back.
它们是背靠背的。
Yeah.
是啊。
没错。
Well, they aired back to back.
嗯，它们是背靠背播出的。
Rob, I have a very strong memory of I think it might have been like season five.
罗伯，我有一个非常深刻的记忆，我想那可能是在第五季。
What was the episode with with Peter Bogdanovich and Michael York where Ted goes to the party?
彼得·博格丹诺维奇和迈克尔·约克客串的那集，泰德去参加派对的那集是什么？
Yeah.
对。
没错。
That's it.
就是那集。
没错。
Peter Bogdanovich obviously this iconic, you know, film director and I'm reciting Dante's Inferno, the opening lines of Dante's Inferno in Italian.
彼得·博格丹诺维奇显然是位标志性的电影导演，而我当时正在用意大利语背诵《但丁神曲》的开篇台词。
And then we started shooting.
然后我们开始拍摄。
But I see Rob go over to Peter Bogdanovich and say can you give him a frame him up?
但我看到罗伯走过去对彼得·博格丹诺维奇说，你能给他构个图吗？
That was Carter Carter, that wasn't you?
那是卡特，卡特，不是你？
Carter was for the means of having to do the movie thing, to the finger frames, it was perfect.
卡特是为了拍电影的那种感觉，用手指比划取景框，那太完美了。
That was a hundred percent Carter, but the other thing with Bogdanovich was intimidating to direct the legendary director and the very first thing we shot was him and the elevator for the tag, and I forget what he was doing.
那百分之百是卡特，但另一件事是，执导这位传奇导演让人感到压力很大，我们拍的第一场戏是他和电梯里的那个标签，我忘了他在做什么。
He was, you know...
他当时，你知道……
He was saying the name, Willam, to fell like a frog.
他在说那个名字，威廉，像只青蛙一样倒下。
Yeah, so he was, of course.
对，他当然在做那个。
Well, that's really what it was.
嗯，那确实就是当时的情况。
And we set it up and he calls me over.
我们布置好场景，他把我叫过去。
We set up the camera, we're all ready to go.
我们架好摄像机，一切准备就绪。
And then he calls me over and goes, won't you want to put the camera closer?
然后他把我叫过去说，你不想把摄像机放近一点吗？
It was like, that's the first thing he said to me.
那是我听到的第一句话。
And I was like, oh, I don't think I do, but now I do.
我说，哦，我本来没想过，但现在我想了。
Yeah, you have to, at that point.
是啊，那时候你必须得那么做。
I don't think he's used to, like, the Zoom lenses.
我觉得他不习惯用变焦镜头。
And I wrote you this little day to send you in New York City.
我给你写了这篇小日记，发给你在纽约。
We'll be right back next to the show.
我们马上回来，继续节目。
So Doug, who's subbing in for our, he's our Alec today.
那么道格，今天代替我们亚历克的人。
Tell us when this episode aired.
告诉我们这一集是什么时候播出的。
Alright.
好的。
to episode 14, Monday Night Football, released February 5th, 2007, this episode was written by Craig Thompson, Carter base.
第14集，《周一橄榄球之夜》，2007年2月5日播出，这一集由克雷格·汤姆森和卡特·贝斯编剧。
I wonder if this was aired the Monday right after the Super Bowl had aired, and that's why we planned it that way, I wish that would have been a great thing for me to have researched out of time.
我怀疑这一集是不是在超级碗结束后的那个周一播出的，所以我们才那样安排，我真希望我能提前查清楚这一点。
When was the Super Bowl that year?
那年的超级碗是什么时候？
Was this literally the Monday after the Super Bowl, and therefore it was like absolutely pretty fun.
这真的是超级碗之后的那个周一吗？所以它当时非常有趣。
I mean, we've talked about this, how linked we were to the changing of the seasons and the holidays.
我的意思是，我们讨论过这一点，我们与季节更替和节假日的联系有多紧密。
That is just not a thing anymore.
现在已经没有那种事了。
I know, it's 10 episodes of something come out, you watch them, whatever the fuck you want.
我知道，现在随便出个10集的东西，你想什么时候看就什么时候看。
We were really, it's almost hard to explain that to like, to the youngs today.
我们当时真的，很难向现在的年轻人解释。
We were really tethered to this idea of like hitting holidays, hitting moments, hitting seasons that all had to match.
我们真的被这种理念束缚住了，比如要赶上节假日，赶上特定时刻，赶上必须匹配的季节。
The networks really liked that to promote it.
电视网真的很喜欢那样来做宣传。
And you were right.
你说得对。
What do you got, Doug?
你查到了吗，道格？
When did it air?
它是什么时候播出的？
Sunday, February 4th.
2月4日，星期日。
It was the Monday after the Super Bowl.
那是超级碗结束后的那个周一。
So it was well planned.
所以这是经过精心策划的。
We planned, we were smart.
我们做了计划，我们很聪明。
And it was the perfect episode to do today.
而且这是今天播出最完美的一集。
Was the Super Bowl on CBS that year?
那年的超级碗是在CBS播出的吗？
I mean, I wonder, it was probably.
我是说，我很好奇，大概是吧。
I think it was, because I think the show might've got promoted on right there.
我想是的，因为我觉得这部剧可能就在那时候做了宣传。
And that's part of why we had the idea to do this.
这也是我们想到要做这一集的部分原因。
Or maybe we were told you're doing a Super Bowl episode.
或者也许是有人告诉我们，你们得拍一集超级碗特辑。
I think we had been encouraged to do that, and then we're like, how do we, encourage, contractually obligated is another way.
我想我们当时是被鼓励这么做的，然后我们就在想，怎么做呢？“鼓励”其实就是合同义务的另一种说法。
And I remember, like, I'm not a football fan, really, if I'm honest, and I remember thinking, how the fuck are we gonna come up with an episode about the Super Bowl?
我记得，说实话，我并不是个橄榄球迷，我记得当时在想，我们到底要怎么想出一个关于超级碗的剧集呢？
But in so many ways, we've done this where you think, How do I do a New Year's Eve episode?
但在很多方面，我们都遇到过这种情况，你会想，我该怎么拍一集除夕夜特辑呢？
And the answer was in season one, they never get to the New Year's Eve party.
答案就是第一季里的那样，他们从来没能去成除夕派对。
You don't even tempts to do New Year's Eve.
你甚至不需要尝试去拍除夕夜。
You do them missing New Year's Eve.
你拍的是他们错过了除夕夜。
Kind of did the same thing here.
这里也差不多是这样。
We had them missing essentially, the Super Bowl, and that was the story.
我们让他们基本上错过了超级碗，这就是故事所在。
What do you got, Doug?
你有什么要说的吗，道格？
And yes, it was CBS, Bears and the Colts.
没错，确实是在CBS，对阵双方是熊队和小马队。
Yeah, it was probably the biggest promotion.
是的，那可能是最大的宣传机会。
We probably got a promo and a Super Bowl if we did a Super Bowl episode, and that was a big deal for us.
如果我们拍一集超级碗特辑，我们可能会得到一个宣传片和超级碗的曝光，这对我们来说是一件大事。
Did we get tickets?
我们拿到票了吗？
It was the real question.
这才是真正的问题。
I don't think we did.
我觉得我们没拿到。
I don't think we did that.
我觉得我们没做到。
Two and a half man got taken to you, exactly.
《好汉两个半》被带去了，没错。
Well, that's a really clever way.
嗯，那真是个非常聪明的方法。
I mean, it's funny to think about, like, how do you write a Super Bowl episode where you're not in Super Bowl?
我是说，想到这一点很有趣，你怎么写一集关于超级碗的剧，但你又不在超级碗现场？
Well, you make it about death and a funeral and all the things that are keeping them from the Super Bowl.
嗯，你让它围绕死亡、葬礼以及所有阻碍他们观看超级碗的事情展开。
Actually seeing it, yeah.
亲眼看到它，是的。
I was really struck in this episode by the construction of it.
这一集的结构让我印象深刻。
So before the cold open, you get, you get the first half premise, which is like, we can't watch the Super Bowl because this guy we barely know died.
所以在冷开场之前，你先得到了前半部分的铺垫，就像是，我们不能看超级碗了，因为这个我们不太熟的人去世了。
and we have to go to this funeral.
我们必须去参加这个葬礼。
So it's such like quick, swift storytelling.
所以这种叙事非常迅速、干脆。
And then the second bit is the Super Bowl happened and now we're gonna try to not learn who won, so we can all watch it together and preserve this tradition.
然后第二部分是超级碗已经结束了，现在我们要努力不去知道谁赢了，这样我们就能一起看比赛，保持这个传统。
I'd forgotten the detail where they get essentially kidnapped by a very drunk Carl the bartender.
我忘了他们被酒鬼酒保卡尔绑架的那个细节了。
That was a delicious one.
那一段真是太精彩了。
I'd forgotten it.
我都忘了。
That's what keeps them told 230 in the morning.
就是那件事让他们一直待到凌晨两点半。
Yeah.
是的。
That was for amusing to me.
那对我来说很有趣。
Rob, what was it like directing this episode?
罗伯，执导这一集是什么感觉？
Let's get into it.
我们深入探讨一下吧。
Let's uh, because you got thrown into the wolves on that first episode where you were literally break You were there broke break glass in case of emergency rob comes out pam goes home sec Columns was the first real one that you weren't just like brought in and then by this one did this feel like okay?
因为你在第一集就被扔进了狼群，当时你简直是……你是去“紧急情况下打破玻璃”，罗伯出场，帕姆回家。这是你真正意义上的第一集，而不是那种被临时拉来的。到了这一集，你有没有觉得“好吧，我现在已经适应了”？
I've got my sea legs doing this now.
我已经掌握窍门了。
This was kind of your third one the first one has an asterisk I mean yeah, and I'm also on stage a lot prior to this anyway as a writer or as a and so it was all felt like home It was easy that way.
这算是你的第三集了，第一集有个星号。我是说，是的，而且在此之前我作为编剧经常在片场，所以一切都感觉像家一样，那样很容易。
I liked everybody.
我喜欢每个人。
I knew everybody.
我认识每个人。
It was you're just and it's all it is a well-oiled machine And you know if I stayed in my office, it probably would look pretty similar and I know that and so I Honor that and there's an incredible template and you kind of just do the template and You add your you can try to add a little here and there, but it is well written and it's pretty clear on the page These were your first big episodes of network TV you directed, right?
这就像是一个运转良好的机器。你知道，如果我待在办公室里，它可能看起来也差不多，我知道这一点，所以我尊重它。这里有一个很棒的模板，你只需要照着模板做，你可以试着在这里或那里加一点自己的东西，但剧本写得很好，页面上的内容也非常清晰。这些是你执导的第一批大型电视网剧集，对吧？你当时刚开始做导演。
You were just starting the director.
我执导过很多单机位剧集，这是我的第一部四机位剧集。
I directed a bunch of single cam, this was my first four camera.
好的，没错，当然，你甚至还做过自己的，对吧？
Okay, right, right, of course, you had done, you had even done your own, right?
那是一个艰难的过渡吗？还是说没什么大不了的，因为……它们是完全不同的技能，我是说，摄像部分是不同的技能组合。
Was that a tough transition or not much at all, just because it's- They're a very different skill, I mean, the camera parts are different skill sets.
没错。
Right.
指导演员的部分是相似的，但摄像部分……我其实觉得单机位更容易。
The directing actors are similar, but the camera parts are, I actually find single camera easier.
而四机位是一种你需要学习的技能。
And that 4K, it's a skill that you need to learn.
我认为一旦你学会了，它就更容易了。
And I think once you've learned it, it's easier.
但它有一个学习曲线。
But it's like there's a learning curve on it.
因为同时发生的事情太多了，你必须知道该看哪里。
Because there's a lot happening at once and you just got it nowhere to look.
没错。
Right.
罗伯，你能告诉我们你是怎么进入编剧室的吗？
Rob, can you tell us like how you found your way into like writer's rooms?
就像是，你是怎么走到今天这一步的简略版？
Like what was your, what's the cliffness version of like how you got to where you got?
我写了，我去了……我是说，整个历史，整个过程。
I wrote, I went to, I mean, the whole history, the whole thing.
我去了戏剧学校。
I went to drama school.
我作为布景设计师去了戏剧学校。
I went to drama school as a set designer.
然后我开始导演。
And then I started directing.
我想导演电影，但我不知道该怎么做。
And I wanted to direct movies and I didn't have any idea how.
所以我开始导演。
So I started directing.
我当时在导演很多朋友的戏剧，我告诉他们，哦，我觉得你应该这样重写，但他们从来不听。
I was directing a lot of my friends' plays and I was telling them, oh, I think you should rewrite it this way and they never would.
所以我说，哦，我最好开始写作。
So then I said, oh, I better start writing.
我从情景喜剧开始，因为它们更短，更像是一口大小的零食。
And I started with sitcoms because they were shorter and more kind of bite-size.
我写了几个样稿，很快、很幸运也很容易地进入了《弗雷泽》剧组。
And I wrote a couple of specs and I got onto a phrase you're pretty quickly and luckily and easily.
仅仅是因为你写的样稿剧本？
Just from spec scripts you had written.
是的。
Yeah.
哇。
Wow.
那是个很好的第一份工作。
That's a good first gig.
事实是，我写了一集《宋飞正传》，我重写了五次，花了一年时间才写完。如果我告诉任何人，没人会雇我。然后我正在写第二个，那时候你需要两个样稿。我当时其实正在写《弗雷泽》，我已经写了四个月了，然后我参加了那个会议。我去了黛安·英格利什的《爱与战争》剧组，我走进会议室说，我们喜欢这个，你能写吗？如果你有两周时间，你能再写一个样稿剧本吗？
truth is I wrote a Seinfeld that I rewrote five time it took about a year to write and if I told anybody that nobody would have hired me and then I was working on the second one those days you needed two specs I was working on a Frasier actually and I was four months into that and I had the meeting I went with I went to the Diane English show with love and war and I went into the meeting and said we like this can you get it can you write if I give you two weeks can you write another respect script.
我没告诉她我已经写了四个月另一个样稿了。
I did not tell her I was four months into another spec script.
我说，两周，那很难。
And I said, two weeks, that's hard.
但我会试试。
But I'll try.
所以我就是这么做的。
And so I that's what I did.
我听你在《爱与战争》回顾播客上讲过这个故事。
I heard you tell the story on the love and worry watch podcast.
罗伯，我很难想象你做其他工作。
Rob, it's hard for me to think about you doing any other job.
就像你刚才说的，说到会计，我无法想象你去办公室工作或者做那种样稿，你看起来就像那种应该出现并想出有趣的东西放在屏幕上的人，我发现我找到了我的使命，你知道吗？
Like the way you were set, I was just like, like speaking of an accountant, like I couldn't see you going to an office job or doing it kind of respect like you just seem like a guy who should be showing up and thinking of funny things to put on screen like that's that's that I found that I found my call you know you really did you really did and you married or not a writer also so yes who also does funny things yeah we just walk around the house being fucking hilarious yeah all day long all day long yeah okay so then you directing this one I like this This one kind of also had a lot, it had a lot of bells and whistles and it had some visual stuff.
你确实找到了，你确实找到了。而且你娶的也不是编剧，对吧？所以是的，她也做有趣的事情。是的，我们整天在家里走来走去，搞笑得要命，整天整天。好的，那么你执导这一集，我喜欢这一集，它也有很多花哨的东西，还有一些视觉上的东西。
So that's what I liked the most.
所以我最喜欢这一点。
So it was fun to do in that sense.
所以从这个意义上说，做起来很有趣。
I really liked the quad split speaking of like the skill of directing multi cam is having a big screen with four boxes in it.
我真的很喜欢四分屏，说到多机位导演的技巧，就是有一个带有四个方框的大屏幕。
And we kind of owned that and did that as a device on this was kind of like a nod to 24, I guess would do stuff like that, the show 24.
我们基本上拥有了它，并把它作为这一集的一个手段，这有点像是向《24小时》致敬，我想《24小时》那部剧会做类似的事情。
That was a fun bell and whistle.
那是一个有趣的花哨手段。
And there was a lot of like the point of view up from the casket.
还有很多从棺材里往外看的视角。
If you also from the Ted's mask, what's that called?
还有泰德的面具，那叫什么来着？
Since we've done better than 5,000.
因为我们已经拍了超过5000集了。
Yeah.
是的。
There was some fun stuff.
有一些有趣的东西。
You had a stunt, you had a flipping not Josh Radner, but kind of looked like Josh Radner.
你有一个替身，你有一个翻滚的……不是乔什·拉德诺，但看起来有点像乔什·拉德诺。
It looked like me.
看起来像我。
I mean, Jordana said, how did you do that?
我是说，乔丹娜说，你是怎么做到的？
It looked really good.
看起来真的很棒。
And I said, I don't believe I did that.
我说，我不相信是我做的。
The thing about that that was fun, I learned the stunt guy came in, and he said, we worked it all out, and then the stunt guy does it, and there's no trick, it just hurts.
关于那件事有趣的地方在于，我了解到特技演员来了，他说，我们把一切都安排好了，然后特技演员就去做了，根本没有什么技巧，就是实打实地疼。
That was the thing that was shocking.
那才是最让人震惊的地方。
The guy just lands on his back and it hurts.
那家伙直接摔在背上，真的很疼。
And then it didn't get it right.
然后还没拍好。
He had to do it again.
他不得不重来一次。
And everyone's like, oh, I'm like grumbling.
大家都在抱怨，我也在嘟囔。
And then we did it again.
然后我们又拍了一次。
But then the stunt guys are always like, all right, cool.
但特技演员总是说，好吧，酷。
Let's do this incredibly painful thing again.
让我们再做一次这件极其痛苦的事情吧。
This poor guy hurts.
这个可怜的家伙很疼。
The old guy just says, yeah, you're doing this one.
那个老家伙只是说，没错，就是你要做这个。
And he looks at me like, all right, I'll do it.
他看着我，好像在说，好吧，我做。
Not only did I notice that it was a stunt guy, but in the construction of the sensory depravator, I said to Jordana, those aren't my hands.
我不仅注意到那是特技演员，而且在搭建感官剥夺装置时，我对乔丹娜说，那不是我的手。
We got a stunt guy for my hands.
我们给我的手找了个替身。
That's really funny.
那真的很有趣。
What were you doing that day?
那天你在做什么？
We couldn't get your hands.
我们没法拍你的手。
Yeah, no idea.
是啊，完全不知道。
No, because the camera guy's right there.
不，因为摄影师就在那儿。
It's probably the camera guy had a wee channel of his own hands.
可能是摄影师自己有一双小手。
But they also had, they had wisps of like, what looked like my hair kind of in the top of the frame.
但他们还有，他们有几缕看起来像我头发的东西在画面上方。
That's really weird.
那真的很奇怪。
I don't remember that way at all.
我一点都不记得是那样了。
That's really funny.
那真的很有趣。
Yeah, I'm certain they weren't my hands.
是的，我确定那不是我的手。
I can confirm that.
我可以证实这一点。
I know what they look like.
我知道它们长什么样。
Yeah, any other strong memories Rob from directing this episode?
是啊，罗伯，执导这一集还有什么深刻的记忆吗？
I had a memory and this is this crazy.
我有一个记忆，这太疯狂了。
I thought, did we at one point with the football guy's name, Emmett Smith?
我想，我们有没有在某个时候和那个橄榄球运动员，埃米特·史密斯？
Did we tackle him?
我们扑倒过他吗？
Was there a bit where we tackled him?
有没有一段是我们扑倒他的戏？
I could have sworn we tackled him.
我敢发誓我们扑倒过他。
That is 100% my memory of it.
那百分之百是我的记忆。
I think we shot a promo for the episode with him.
我想我们和他一起拍了一段这一集的宣传片。
Oh, okay.
哦，好吧。
That's right.
没错。
That's what it was.
原来是这样。
So you did it, you're not listening.
所以你做到了，你没在听。
I remember I got the direct tackling Emmett Smith.
我记得我指挥了扑倒埃米特·史密斯的戏。
Was it all five of us tackling him, or was it just Neil?
是我们五个人一起扑倒他，还是只有尼尔？
Something like that.
差不多是那样。
Yeah, I think it was all of us.
是的，我想是我们所有人。
And that was the promo that aired during Super Bowl.
那是超级碗期间播出的宣传片。
Yeah, there you go.
是的，就是这样。
I knew I remembered that.
我就知道我记得。
And remind me, I'm just now remembering this.
提醒我一下，我现在才想起来。
Did he say dance because he had just one dancing with the stars?
他是不是说了跳舞，因为他刚参加完《与星共舞》？
Yes, there are a few things in here that you're like, what the fuck was that?
是的，这里面有一些东西会让你觉得，那到底是什么鬼？
Again, there's a little more topicality in this one than there are in some others.
再说一次，这一集比其他集有更多的时事梗。
Like the reference to like the Janet Jackson thing.
比如提到珍妮·杰克逊那件事。
Well, that's funny.
嗯，那很有趣。
That's funny.
那很有趣。
That was funny.
Do people still know that?
人们现在还知道那个吗？
Oh, I think that's, that's entered the cultural kind of Let's go.
哦，我想那已经进入了文化……让我们继续吧。
Old tech flag though, prayer over Tivo.
不过那是老技术警报，Tivo的祈祷。
Oh my God, the Tivo prayer.
哦天哪，Tivo祈祷。
That made me sad a little bit.
那让我有点难过。
I was like, oh boy, Tivo.
我就想，哦天哪，Tivo。
Yeah.
是啊。
It's great.
太棒了。
I love the bit.
我喜欢这个桥段。
It was a great thing.
那是个很棒的东西。
You guys did it great.
你们演得很好。
But it was like, oh, that's that's old tech.
但就像是，哦，那是老技术了。
That's what the office ladies say.
这就是《办公室》那些女士们说的。
They say old tech alert, so we're stealing that from that.
她们说老技术警报，所以我们是从那儿偷来的。
Emmet Smith said that he was recognized way more for dancing with the stars than he was for being a Hall of Fame football player.
埃米特·史密斯说，他因为《与星共舞》而被认出来的次数，远多于他作为名人堂橄榄球运动员被认出来的次数。
I was a little tidded.
我当时有点不爽。
Oh my God.
哦天哪。
And that was like a rival show that was like kicking our ass.
那是一个当时正在痛扁我们的竞争对手节目。
So it's probably panned us a little to reference them at all.
所以提到他们可能让我们有点痛苦。
But anyway, but I forgot, it took me a second watching that.
但不管怎样，我忘了，看的时候花了我一秒钟。
I was like, oh, is that what that was?
我就想，哦，原来是那个啊？
He was dancing with stars 2019 years later.
他参加《与星共舞》已经是19年前的事了。
That reference doesn't totally hold up, but here we are.
那个梗不太经得起推敲，但我们还是用了。
And then my only other strong memory was when Neil is handcuffed to the radiator.
我唯一的另一个深刻记忆是尼尔被铐在暖气片上的时候。
And he says, in my bookie, he worries.
他说，在我的书里，他担心。
He worries, and I remember 100%, it was like more Jewish, now a little less Jewish, right there.
他担心，我百分之百记得，当时我说的是更犹太一点，现在少一点犹太味，就在那儿。
That was, and I use that direction all the time.
那是，我一直用那个指导。
Do it to me, you get a style.
对我做，你得到一种风格。
I always give more Jewish, less Jewish.
我总是说更犹太一点，少犹太一点。
I use it shockingly, yeah.
我用得非常频繁，真的。
It's actually your only direction.
那其实是你唯一的指导方式。
Exactly, and louder, quite.
没错，还有大声点，安静点。
I will say I always hit the sweet spot.
我会说我总是能抓住重点。
Exactly, he did.
没错，他做到了。
He worries was really good.
他担心演得真好。
That was really funny.
那真的很有趣。
He worries.
他担心。
It's a very physical episode.
这是一集非常注重肢体动作的剧集。
There's a lot of running around and then seeing like stunts and that little kid extorting Marshall was really funny.
有很多跑来跑去的戏，还有看到特技，那个勒索马歇尔的小孩真的很有趣。
Yeah, I actually really, one thing I really liked about that little kid and sometimes with Lillie's classroom, like the little kid humor was like pretty uncentimetal.
是的，我真的很喜欢那个小孩，有时候在莉莉的教室里，那种小孩的幽默感相当不感伤。
Like this kid's quite evil.
就像这个孩子相当邪恶。
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
Like he's not a good little saintly boy.
他不是那种善良的小圣人。
Yeah.
是的。
He's like a scheming little kid.
他就像个爱算计的小鬼。
Yeah.
是啊。
And I think it's funny to be super uncentimetal about that stuff.
我觉得对那些事情表现得极其不感伤挺有趣的。
And yeah, that's a young Steven Miller.
没错，那是年轻时的史蒂文·米勒。
Yeah, I think it was a young Steven Lloyd, it could also be a he was a good kid.
是啊，我觉得那是年轻时的史蒂文·劳埃德，也可能是他当时是个好孩子。
The kid that kid was good.
那孩子，那孩子很不错。
He was really funny.
他真的很风趣。
Rob, I feel like this was your joke is Rob, of course, is also a writer and would come in and pitch up the car and I wrote this episode.
罗伯，我觉得这是你的笑话，罗伯当然也是编剧，他会进来提议，我写了这一集。
I don't think we wrote this joke.
我不觉得这个笑话是我们写的。
The thing where the kid says, you know, $10 and Marshall Demiros and the kid goes, it just went up to eight.
就是那个孩子说，你知道，10美元和马歇尔·德米罗斯，然后孩子说，刚刚涨到8美元了。
It's one of my favorite.
这是我最喜欢的笑话之一。
I love that.
我喜欢那个。
I love that I don't know if it's mine, but I did love it.
我喜欢那个，我不知道是不是我写的，但我确实很喜欢。
It's such a good joke.
这真是个好笑话。
It's a joke joke.
这真是个笑话。
I don't think we wrote I'm not being jealous, like I wish that was our joke.
我不觉得是我们写的，我不是在嫉妒，我只是希望那是我们的笑话。
You have to really, that's a joke you're like, if he's bad at math, well he's bad at teaching math.
你必须得承认，那个笑话让你觉得，如果他数学不好，嗯，他教数学也不怎么样。
The joke is that he's not teaching math very well.
笑点在于他数学教得不好。
That could fly by you, that joke, but it's so funny.
那个笑话可能会被你忽略，但它真的很有趣。
Yeah, totally.
是啊，完全同意。
And I think I remember with that kid that kid was great, but I basically told Jason, just direct him.
我记得那个孩子很棒，但我基本上告诉杰森，你去指导他就行。
Jason and him weren't sitting there, and I said, well, you're sitting alone and Jason basically directed him, he was great.
杰森和他在那儿，我说，你们坐着，杰森基本上指导了他，他表现得很棒。
Oh, that's funny.
哦，那很有趣。
That's always a good way with kids, I think that after if they connect, that they can do more than I do.
我觉得和孩子合作，这总是一个好方法，如果他们能建立联系，他们能做的比我多。
It also means less work for you, so it was like pretty.
这也意味着你的工作量减少了，所以这挺好的。
Exactly.
没错。
Yeah.
是啊。
You're just back there at the monitor, yelling more Jewish, or less Jewish, exactly.
你只是在监视器后面，大喊“更犹太一点”或者“没那么犹太”，就是这样。
So the kid, he's like, I don't know what you mean.
所以那个孩子说，我不知道你是什么意思。
I don't know.
我不知道。
I hear.
我听到了。
I feel wrong.
我觉得不对劲。
And then I hear Jason whispering more Jewish.
然后我听到杰森在耳语“更犹太一点”。
To the kid.
对那个孩子说。
It just went up, dang.
刚刚涨价了，该死。
I thought our oversized suits were really funny, and we looked like we were signing for the NBA draft.
我觉得我们那些超大号的西装真的很好笑，我们看起来就像要去参加NBA选秀一样。
That was, yeah.
那是，没错。
That was really funny.
那真的很有趣。
You know what struck me at the beginning of this episode?
你知道这一集开头什么让我印象深刻吗？
All of a sudden our cast for just like one act of the show is Seinfeld.
突然间，我们这一集的演员阵容就像是《宋飞正传》一样。
They don't give a shit about this guy who died.
他们根本不在乎这个死掉的人。
Right.
对。
They don't know who he was.
他们根本不知道他是谁。
Like this is a Seinfeld bit.
这就像是《宋飞正传》里的桥段。
It was funny because usually we're such an emo show.
这很有趣，因为我们通常是一部情感丰富的剧。
It's so heartfelt.
非常感人。
But these guys had no idea who this guy who died was and they just want to not go to the funeral.
但这些人根本不知道死者是谁，他们只是不想去参加葬礼。
I was like this feels almost not like our gang at the very beginning.
我觉得这在开头看起来几乎不像我们这帮人。
It was funny.
这很有趣。
Yeah.
是啊。
But it was like a little darker than we said.
但这比我们平时要黑暗一点。
The coffin shot of them recognizing him and get remembering who he was is fantastic.
棺材那一幕，他们认出他并想起他是谁，真是太棒了。
Really funny.
真的很有趣。
Well-directed Rob.
导演得好，罗伯。
Yeah, it's a real old-school bit.
是啊，这是老派的桥段。
My specialty.
我的专长。
Okay, so all of the various bells and whistles, was this the hardest one you had directed of the three?
好了，那么所有的这些花哨的东西，这是你执导的三集中最难的一集吗？
Because I feel like columns was a little more straightforward.
因为我觉得《Columns》那一集更直白一些。
Scorpion the Told was a lot of talking at bars and stuff.
《Scorpion and the Toad》里有很多在酒吧里的对话之类的。
This had a lot more.
这一集内容更多。
The bells and whistles are more fun for me than a big party scene where everyone's talking around.
对我来说，这些花哨的东西比那种大家都在说话的大型派对场景更有趣。
I love all that, the bells and whistles.
我喜欢所有那些花哨的东西。
The more filming stuff is where I love the most.
我最喜欢拍摄那些东西。
Yeah, yeah, I mean, it worked great.
是啊，是啊，我的意思是，效果很好。
I had not watched this episode in a really long time.
我已经很久没看这一集了。
I had forgotten things about it, even though we wrote it.
我甚至忘记了其中的一些细节，尽管是我们写的。
Carter and I, it really moves, it really cooks this episode.
卡特和我，这一集节奏真的很快，非常紧凑。
You really feel the ticking clock, You really feel like there's real stakes.
你真的能感觉到时间的流逝，你真的觉得有真正的赌注。
And it's funny, because then you remember it's just them watching a T-vode Super Bowl.
这很有趣，因为后来你记得这只是他们在看电视上的超级碗。
The stakes aren't that high, but it feels like very tense and suspenseful.
赌注其实没那么高，但感觉非常紧张和悬疑。
And I think you did a great job keeping that energy kind of like a live wire through the whole episode.
我觉得你做得很好，让那种能量在整集中像带电的导线一样贯穿始终。
You kept energy up.
你保持了那种能量。
Was that, what was that like?
那是，那是什么感觉？
Cause it's a three day shoot and you have to play it all like an action movie with a ticking clock, what was that?
因为这是三天的拍摄，你必须像拍动作片一样，有倒计时，那是什么感觉？
I don't remember that, but I think it was on the page and it was in the editing.
我不记得了，但我认为这在剧本里，也在剪辑里。
and the actors were great, but I think a lot of that was editing and Chris editing it, but yeah.
演员们都很棒，但我认为很大程度上归功于剪辑和克里斯的剪辑，但确实。
Good music, too.
音乐也不错。
It had good like 24 hour drama kind of music.
它有那种24小时剧情片风格的音乐。
Well, it's also, it's a kind of comedic trope to take something just triflingly un-serious, or the stakes are so low and make it such high stakes.
嗯，这也是一种喜剧套路，把一些微不足道、不严肃的事情，或者赌注很低的事情，搞得像赌注很高一样。
Oh, that's my favorite trope, yeah, I love that.
哦，那是我最喜欢的套路，是的，我喜欢那个。
But there is something underneath Ted's, you know, we talk a lot about like vertical family versus horizontal family, and this is like, I don't know if you'd heard this, Robert.
但在泰德的内心深处，你知道，我们经常谈论垂直家庭和水平家庭，我不知道你是否听说过这个，罗伯特。
I heard that all TV is about family.
我听说所有的电视剧都是关于家庭的。
Like everything is about family on television.
就像电视上的一切都是关于家庭的。
Soprano is about, you know, cheers is about family, phrases is about family.
《黑道家族》是关于这个的，你知道，《欢乐酒店》是关于家庭的，《弗雷泽》是关于家庭的。
And this show is about people who choose family.
而这部剧是关于那些选择家庭的人。
They choose who their family is.
他们选择谁是他们的家人。
So there's something in Ted's obsession with this tradition, even though he blacked out the first time he declared it was gonna be a tradition.
所以泰德对这个传统的执着是有原因的，尽管他第一次宣布要把它作为传统时喝断片了。
But this idea that like, we have to do this together, it, I could make the argument that, at least from Ted's perspective, this is meaningful in a much deeper way, even though you can kind of shrug it off, it's just the Super Bowl.
但这种想法，即我们必须一起做这件事，我可以争辩说，至少从泰德的角度来看，这有着更深层的意义，尽管你可以把它当作只是超级碗而不屑一顾。
Yeah, it is meaningful.
是啊，它确实有意义。
And I thought the ending, I thought it was poignant at the end, I thought Bob, I really liked Bob Saggot at the end of this episode.
我觉得结尾很感人，我真的很喜欢这一集结尾的鲍勃·萨格。
And really the narration, Bob was like just doing good narration acting at the end.
而且鲍勃的旁白确实演得很好。
And I liked his take on not remembering who won the game.
我喜欢他关于不记得谁赢了比赛的看法。
There's something so great about this episode that's all about who won the game.
这一集关于谁赢了比赛的内容真的很棒。
And then Future Ted says, I don't remember.
然后未来的泰德说，我不记得了。
And we never say it, we never talk about it.
我们从来没说，从来没讨论过。
I will say that, Jordana, my wife, who, it's so funny, we recently gotten a number of letters and comments from people, including the opening letter today, because Jordana, if you've noticed, hasn't been doing her therapist observes, watches how I made your mother for the first time.
我要说的是，我的妻子乔丹娜，很有趣，我们最近收到了一些信件和评论，包括今天开头的信，因为乔丹娜，如果你注意到了，她没有在做她的“治疗师观察”，第一次看《老爸老妈浪漫史》。
And we revealed, and I think two episodes ago, that we had a baby a couple weeks ago.
我们透露了，我想是两集之前，我们几周前生了个孩子。
So, so, Jordana has taken, um, leave maternity leave from her duties on this podcast.
所以，乔丹娜已经休了产假，暂停了她在播客上的职责。
But I will say, she probably would have, if she was doing one this week, she would have probably used this quote, which she leaned over to me at the end of the episode.
但我得说，如果她这周还在做的话，她可能会引用这句话，她在这一集结尾时凑过来对我说。
And she reminded me, there's a Whitman quote that is actually on a bench in Fort Green that we pass all the time, Fort Green Park.
她提醒我，有一句惠特曼的诗句实际上刻在堡垒格林公园的一张长椅上，我们经常经过那里。
And it's from Leaves of Grass.
那是出自《草叶集》。
And it simply says, we were together, I forget the rest.
它只是说，我们在一起，其余的我都忘了。
And to me, that's kind of what this episode is.
对我来说，这一集差不多就是这个意思。
we were together, I forget the rest.
我们在一起，其余的我都忘了。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
That's great.
太棒了。
The details don't matter.
细节并不重要。
It's about the camaraderie, even the attempt to have this shared experience together.
重要的是情谊，甚至是那种试图共同拥有这段经历的尝试。
That's what Ted's trying to create as a shared experience.
这就是泰德试图创造的共同经历。
But I also loved, and we talk about this, Craig, like, so the thought experiment is they each have to not learn the score, the Super Bowl.
但我还喜欢一点，我们讨论过这个，克雷格，思想实验是他们每个人都必须不去了解超级碗的比分。
What does that look like for Ted?
这对泰德来说是什么样的？
What does that look like for Barney?
这对巴尼来说是什么样的？
What does that look like for Marshall?
这对马歇尔来说是什么样的？
What does that look like for Robin?
这对罗宾来说是什么样的？
So you have you have Robin and the you know on the local news like how does that play out with her?
所以你有罗宾，你知道在当地新闻里，这对她来说会怎么发展？
Yeah, you know Lily in the classroom with Marshall.
是的，你知道莉莉在教室里和马歇尔在一起。
How does that play out?
那会怎么发展？
Like I imagine that's a really fun thing in a writer's room like to crack each version of that story It is I remember being very fun to crack that and I remember rewatching it now It was like Marshall's is the biggest reach so there's no reason Marshall had to be in Lily's classroom He is for show and tell, which I thought was really funny, which is, yeah, that was really funny.
我想在编剧室里构思每个版本的故事一定很有趣，我记得构思那个过程非常有趣，现在重看时，我觉得马歇尔的那部分最牵强，因为马歇尔没有理由非得在莉莉的教室里，他是为了“展示与讲述”环节，我觉得这真的很有趣，是的，那真的很有趣。
And I do these going to hide out there because that's a safe space.
我去做这些是为了躲在那里，因为那是个安全空间。
We're not going to be talking about the super like, guess that worked.
我们不会谈论超级碗，猜猜看，这招奏效了。
That one felt like a little bit of a reach because I was doing the same calculus.
那一段感觉有点牵强，因为我也在做同样的计算。
I was like, what did we do for everybody?
我在想，我们为每个人做了什么？
I was a fun puzzle to crack, Marshall's like a little forced, but we knew he liked the bit of the kid extorting him.
这是一个有趣的难题，马歇尔的那部分有点强行植入，但我们知道他喜欢那个孩子勒索他的桥段。
So we're like, all right, we're just going to pretend this makes any sense.
所以我们想，好吧，我们就假装这说得通。
And it puts him with Lily, you just wanted him, you just wanted him to spray apple juice on a kid's crotch.
这让他和莉莉在一起，你只是想让他把苹果汁喷在孩子的裤裆上。
And you worked backwards from there.
你是从那个点倒推回来的。
That's where the entire episode came from that moment.
整集内容都是从那一刻衍生出来的。
And then the network said it has to be a Super Bowl episode.
然后电视台说这必须是一集超级碗特辑。
So you excited?
所以你兴奋吗？
So like, all right, why wouldn't you be doing that to a kid?
所以就像，好吧，为什么你不能对孩子那样做呢？
We were first engineered it.
我们是先设计好的。
That's really funny.
那真的很有趣。
Yeah, I that was the one that I was like, we reached for that one a little bit, but it was so funny.
是的，那是让我觉得我们稍微有点牵强的一段，但它太搞笑了。
It felt like sitcom logic that made sense to me.
我觉得这符合情景喜剧的逻辑，对我来说说得通。
Yeah, I kind of goes by like, all right, I'm in.
是的，我有点觉得，好吧，我接受。
Yeah, I thought the the guy who played the it wasn't Sandy Rivers, but the guy who played the anchor with the copie did a great job He was funny.
是的，我觉得那个扮演……不是桑迪·里弗斯，但那个扮演带假发的播音员的人表现得很棒，他很有趣。
He did a really good job.
他做得非常好。
I don't know.
我不知道。
I'm taking on Ducey Ducey as his name I know that guy.
我记得他叫杜西，我认识那个人。
Yeah, he was he was the I Used to know he's a good guy.
是的，他以前是……我认识他，他是个好人。
Funny.
很有趣。
He was great.
他很棒。
He was great that whole that whole newsroom sequence really worked Well, I thought it's so fun.
他很棒，整个新闻编辑室的片段效果非常好，我觉得太有趣了。
That was fun.
那很有趣。
I mean in directing wise it was fun to the guys The news guys had it like oh how to improvise with the camera.
我的意思是，从导演的角度来看，新闻组的人很有趣，比如如何即兴配合摄像机。
I did like how the camera just was a character in the scene.
我确实喜欢摄像机在场景中作为一个角色的设定。
They were trying to play ketchup, basically.
他们基本上是在试图追赶进度。
Right.
没错。
Because it wasn't going as planned, yeah.
因为事情没有按计划进行，是的。
The shitty pan over to the weather guy and it's a green screen and then it just kills him.
那个糟糕的镜头平移到天气预报员身上，结果是绿幕，然后直接毁了。
The weather map fills in at a certain point behind him as he's eating the donut.
当他在吃甜甜圈时，天气预报图在某个时刻填满了身后的屏幕。
That was, you've got to direct the hell out of this one because all of those bits about the timing of how that camera's moving, the news camera, it really was well exchanged.
那一段，你必须得把导演工作做到极致，因为所有关于摄像机移动时机的细节，那个新闻摄像机，真的配合得很好。
I also like the rewritten stuff for Robin when she's just generically talking about the winning team and the delicacy.
我也喜欢罗宾重写的内容，当她只是泛泛地谈论获胜的球队和美食时。
That was great.
那太棒了。
And this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you, New York City.
还有那个老头，他……爱上了你，纽约市。
And now, commercials.
现在，广告时间。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
嗨，我是亚历克斯·戈德曼，《Hyper-Fixed》播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
like, I'm 30, and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如，我30岁了，但我不敢在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者，为什么我在倒车时不能调节车载音响的音量？
We also solve non-car-related problems.
我们也解决非汽车相关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果你有问题，我们不仅会解决它，还会揭露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这是来自Radiotopia的《Hyper-Fixed》播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
在任何你收听播客的地方或访问HyperFixedPod.com即可找到。
End of commercials?
广告结束了吗？
Back to Shell.
回到节目。
One thing that we discovered, I think recently, probably before we even, after we booked you to come on, Rob, is this episode, and Doug, I'm going to throw it to a clip here.
有一件事我们最近才发现，可能是在我们预定你来参加节目之后，罗伯，关于这一集，道格，我要放一段剪辑。
This episode was selected when we, a variety did a piece when we hit 20 years, 20 years since the pilot, which was in September, variety did a piece where they did the top 20 episodes, the top 20 funniest or most beloved episodes, according to this one writer, Andrew McGowan, And he chose this one as his top, because it exhibited, I guess, the platonic ideal of what how much mother episode was to him.
这一集被选中是因为当我们纪念开播20周年时，《综艺》杂志做了一篇报道，那是九月份，他们评选了前20集，根据一位叫安德鲁·麦高恩的作者，选出了最有趣或最受喜爱的20集，他选择了这一集作为第一名，因为他认为这展现了《老爸老妈浪漫史》对他而言的柏拉图式理想。
And that may or may not be my pen name, but yeah, we've never met Andrew again, exactly.
那可能是我用的笔名，也可能不是，但我们确实从未见过安德鲁，没错。
And we have a clip.
我们有一段剪辑。
Here is Andrew McGowan.
这是安德鲁·麦高恩。
Let's decide if it sounds like Rob doing a voice.
让我们听听这听起来像不像罗伯在配音。
I don't think it will, but there's always that chance.
我觉得不像，但总是有那种可能。
We have a clip.
我们有一段剪辑。
heard we were doing this, and he wanted to weigh in and explain why he selected it as his top choice.
听说我们要录这个，他想发表意见并解释为什么他把它选为第一名。
So let's listen to Variety writer, Andrew McGowan.
所以让我们听听《综艺》杂志作者安德鲁·麦高恩的声音。
Hi, Craig.
嗨，克雷格。
Hi, Josh.
嗨，乔什。
Hi, Alec, and hi, Rob.
嗨，亚历克，还有嗨，罗伯。
A belated congratulations on 20 years since the premiere of How I Met Your Mother.
迟到的祝贺，《老爸老妈浪漫史》开播20周年快乐。
For the milestone anniversary, I had the pleasure of revisiting the show and ranking the top 20 episodes for a variety.
为了这个里程碑式的纪念日，我有幸重温了这部剧，并为《综艺》杂志评选了前20集。
The criteria was not an exact science, but I broadly weighed each episode based on its writing, direction, premise, humor, heart and message.
评选标准并非精确的科学，但我大致根据每集的剧本、导演、前提、幽默感、情感和传达的信息进行了权衡。
While there were many episodes that pained me not to include on the list, I think that I always knew that Monday Night Football would top it.
虽然有很多集没能入选让我感到痛苦，但我认为我一直都知道《周一橄榄球之夜》会名列榜首。
The episode, I believe, epitomizes how I met your mother at its best.
我相信这一集是《老爸老妈浪漫史》巅峰时期的缩影。
It's sort of a timeless episode, one that a seasoned fan of the show and a newcomer can appreciate equally.
这算是一集永恒的剧集，无论是老粉丝还是新观众都能同样欣赏。
The premise is relatable, not just of friends watching the Super Bowl together, but of friends trying to share a common experience and keep a tradition alive against the odds.
前提很有共鸣，不仅仅是朋友们一起看超级碗，而是朋友们试图分享共同经历，并克服困难保持传统。
And in facing those odds, we get to see each of the characters showcase some of their most quintessential qualities across this one main A story that splinters in four different ways.
在面对这些困难时，我们看到了每个角色在这一条主线故事中展现出他们最典型的特质，而这条主线又分成了四个不同的方向。
Barney's emotional zanniness and unhinged mystery is shown through his gambling addiction, Robin's unglamorous life as a local newscaster is seen and how unprofessional she can get away with acting on air.
巴尼的情感疯狂和难以捉摸的神秘感通过他的赌博成瘾展现出来，罗宾作为当地新闻主播不光鲜的生活，以及她在直播中能表现得多么不专业。
Marshall's conflict with the five-year-old in Lily's class shows his boyish endearing demeanor and Ted's innovation and excitement with the sensory depurator 5,000 brings out his geekiness.
马歇尔与莉莉班上五岁孩子的冲突展现了他孩子气且可爱的一面，而泰德对“感官剥夺器5000”的创新和兴奋则带出了他的极客气质。
But of course it's the end of the episode that I believe elevated above the rest, how they all fail to evade the score of the game, but still walk the game together and realize that it's the time spent together that brings value to the tradition.
但当然，我相信是这一集的结尾让它超越了其他剧集，他们都未能避开比赛比分，但仍然一起走完了比赛，并意识到在一起度过的时光才赋予了传统价值。
When Future Ted narrates that all these years later, he can't remember who won or who even played the game, but he remembers eating wings, laughing, hanging out with his friends.
当未来的泰德叙述说，多年以后，他不记得谁赢了，甚至不记得谁参加了比赛，但他记得吃鸡翅、大笑、和朋友们在一起。
I think that really encapsulates the show's broader meaning, more so than the engine of Ted meeting the mother.
我认为这真正概括了这部剧更广泛的意义，比泰德寻找老妈的引擎更重要。
How I met your mother, I believe, is about friendship.
我相信《老爸老妈浪漫史》是关于友谊的。
It's about a time in one's young adulthood when friends serve as family and the most important memories are not necessarily defined by the headline events, but rather by who you share them with.
它是关于一个人年轻时的那段时光，朋友们就像家人一样，最重要的记忆不一定是由重大事件定义的，而是由你与谁分享这些时刻定义的。
So that's why I ranked Monday Night Football at the top of the list.
这就是为什么我把《周一橄榄球之夜》排在榜首。
Thank you all so much for creating this wonderful series that means so much to me and so much to so many.
非常感谢你们创作了这部精彩的剧集，它对我以及许多人来说意义重大。
Overall, there is so much to learn from appreciate and empathize with over the course of the nine seasons.
总的来说，在九季的过程中，有很多值得学习、欣赏和共鸣的地方。
And it will always hold a special place in my heart.
它将永远在我心中占据特殊的位置。
So thank you again and congratulations again.
所以再次感谢你们，再次祝贺你们。
Craig, I hope to catch up with you soon.
克雷格，希望很快能和你叙旧。
And gosh, Alec Rob, I hope to cross paths with you in the future.
天哪，Alec，Rob，希望未来我们还能再相见。
Thank you so much.
非常感谢。
That's great, Andrew.
太棒了，Andrew。
That was such a thoughtful and smart.
这真是太深刻、太聪明了。
And Rob, how do you feel about that?
Rob，你对此有什么感觉？
You helmed the episode.
这集是你执导的。
He said is the best one to him at of 200 days.
他说这是他200天里看过最好的一集。
Well, I think it is what Josh said, it was like it's about the most mundane thing.
嗯，我想正如Josh所说，它讲的是最平凡不过的事情。
So the other, the emotion came through.
所以，那种情感才得以流露出来。
If it was a more important event, it wouldn't have been as impactful.
如果这是一个更重大的事件，反而不会有这么大的冲击力。
Right, right.
对，没错。
Yeah.
是啊。
You know, I just this morning started listening to Ezra Klein just posted like an episode of his show from 2023.
你知道，今天早上我刚开始听Ezra Klein发布的一期2023年的节目。
And it's with an author who wrote a book about hanging out.
嘉宾是一位写过关于“闲逛”这本书的作者。
the pleasures of hanging out with, for no particular reason, and how we don't do it anymore.
书中谈到了无所事事地闲逛的乐趣，以及为什么我们现在不再那样做了。
And there's this real, you know, there's much written about the kind of loneliness epidemic and isolation and what the phones are doing to us, but they really interrogate, I've only listened to about 20 minutes of it, but they really interrogate this kind of lost world of hanging out, which this show is, if any show is a hanging out show, how we met mothers a hanging out show.
关于孤独流行病、社会隔绝以及手机对我们的影响，已经有很多论述了，但他们深入探讨了——我只听了大约20分钟——他们深入探讨了这种“闲逛”的失落世界，而如果说有什么节目是关于闲逛的，《老爸老妈浪漫史》就是一部关于闲逛的剧。
And they're just, they're sitting around that booth, drinking beer, making each other laugh, for no reason other than the delight in each other's company.
他们只是坐在那个卡座里，喝着啤酒，逗彼此发笑，除了享受彼此的陪伴之外，没有任何其他理由。
Yeah.
是啊。
And I think in the same way that Gen Z loves hearing about like 90s childhoods, like 80s, 90s analog childhoods, because it starts to feel like this lost world that they never got to know because they all had digital childhoods.
我觉得就像Z世代喜欢听关于90年代童年，那种80、90年代模拟时代童年的故事一样，因为那开始感觉像是一个他们从未经历过的失落世界，毕竟他们拥有的是数字化的童年。
And I think part of the, one of the things, Rob, that we're really interrogating on the show like the long tail of it, why people still watch it and care about it and other shows that were even more popular than we were on when we were on the air have kind of faded in the cultural memory.
我想，Rob，我们在节目中深入探讨的一点，也就是它的长尾效应，为什么人们至今仍在观看并关心它，而其他在播出时比我们更受欢迎的节目却在文化记忆中逐渐淡去。
But for some reason, this show still has a beating heart and a place in the cultural firmament.
但出于某种原因，这部剧依然有着跳动的心脏，在文化领域占有一席之地。
So, I think that's one of the reasons.
所以，我认为这就是原因之一。
There's something pleasurable about watching people face to face care about each other, live life together, share experiences together, celebrate holidays and super bowls together.
看着人们面对面地关心彼此、共同生活、分享经历、一起庆祝节日和超级碗，这本身就是一种享受。
There's something, it touches something in us that we all want, but might not currently have.
它触动了我们内心深处都渴望、但目前可能并未拥有的东西。
I think that's right.
我想你是对的。
I think it scratches an itch.
我觉得它挠到了痒处。
I think there's something about seeing, even that they all decide this is important.
我觉得看到他们所有人都认为这很重要，这本身就很有意义。
They all decide it's so important not to hear this result.
他们都认为不去听那个结果非常重要。
Yeah.
是啊。
And there's a funny thing, like even though I said they were a bit callous about poor Mark who died, there's a funny kind of thematic overlap of like, well, that's how it ends for everybody.
还有件有趣的事，虽然我说他们对可怜的Mark的死有点冷漠，但这里有一种有趣的、关于“这就是每个人的结局”的主题重叠。
So eventually we all die at some point.
所以最终我们所有人都会死。
And this idea of what's so great about the ending or the results, right?
关于结局或结果，到底有什么了不起的呢？
Who cares who won that game?
谁在乎那场比赛谁赢了？
Who cares what the end is?
谁在乎结局是什么？
The end is, you know, the ultimate end is we all die.
结局就是，你知道，最终的结局是我们都会死。
Well, that's also, but we better enjoy watching the fucking game together as the most important part.
嗯，确实如此，但我们最好还是享受一起看那场该死的比赛，这才是最重要的部分。
The end result is not the most important thing.
最终结果并不是最重要的。
Well Craig, that's what our kind of response is when people say like, this could have been 15 minutes.
嗯，Craig，当人们说“这集本来可以缩短到15分钟”时，我们的回应就是这样。
It's like, well, that's not an interesting show.
就像是，嗯，那样的节目就没意思了。
You know, like the entire show was always about the journey.
你知道，整部剧一直以来都是关于过程的。
It was always about, and when people would get upset, you know, when the show was on the air, there were certain how I made your mother obsessives that were obsessed with who the mother was.
一直都是这样，当人们感到沮丧时，你知道，当剧集还在播出时，有一些《老爸老妈浪漫史》的死忠粉，他们沉迷于“老妈”到底是谁。
Like that was the big mystery to crack as if this was like a true crime podcast or something.
好像这是什么需要破解的重大谜案，就像在听真实犯罪播客一样。
But that was never the thing.
但那从来都不是重点。
I mean, it was a fun thing to hang it on.
我的意思是，把它作为一个噱头很有趣。
and it probably helped you guys sell the show to have a kind of hook, but that was never the thing.
而且这可能确实帮助你们卖掉了这部剧，因为它有一个钩子，但那从来都不是重点。
The thing was always, how do we create a context where people can hang out and love each other and laugh?
重点始终是，我们如何创造一个环境，让人们可以聚在一起、相爱并欢笑。
And I think maybe Andrew was hinting at that in his thoughtful answer too.
我想Andrew在他那深思熟虑的回答中可能也暗示了这一点。
Like there's something, this is in miniature the entire series in some way.
就像在某种程度上，这集是整个系列的缩影。
Yeah, there's gonna be a result, there's gonna be a score.
是的，会有结果，会有比分。
There will be a thing ascertained and the clock will stop and it'll be a result and they don't remember what the fucking result is.
事情总会水落石出，时钟会停止，会有个结果，但他们根本不记得那个该死的结果是什么。
The whole episode is about that and you never hear what it is.
整集都在讲这个，但你永远不知道那到底是什么。
And I think that's a really great way to say it's the journey that matters.
我觉得这是一种很好的表达方式，说明过程才是最重要的。
And it's being together that matters.
在一起才是最重要的。
Yeah.
没错。
Well, it wasn't also there was a little bit of a wink to the series, because in the narrate at the very end, he says like, even though you know how it's gonna end, that's not the point.
嗯，这其实也算是对剧集本身的一点致敬，因为在最后旁白里，他说即使你知道结局会怎样，那也不是重点。
That's not the point.
那不是重点。
And he's telling his kids about their mother, they know how it is.
他是在跟孩子们讲他们母亲的故事，他们知道结局。
So it's not about that.
所以重点不在那儿。
Yeah, it's not about them.
对，重点不在那儿。
Yeah, and like we talk about the best how many mother episodes are kind of like, They're self-contained, you can watch them.
是啊，就像我们讨论《老爸老妈浪漫史》里最好的那些集数一样，它们是独立的，你可以单独观看。
I think we know the best one, however, but go on.
我想我们都知道最好的是哪一集，不过你继续说。
You're gonna be dining out on this for years.
你以后好几年都要拿这个说事儿了。
But we can watch it as a self-contained story, but it also kind of winks at our gestures towards the larger story that it's a part of.
我们可以把它当作一个独立的故事来看，但它也以某种方式呼应或指向了它所属的那个更大的故事。
The mini mystery, the mystery and miniature.
微型谜题，缩影式的谜题。
How are they gonna, this has a little bit of that too.
他们会怎么做，这一集也有点那种感觉。
It's not quite exactly, exactly.
不完全是，确实不完全是。
And also, it was funny, I think it was Atlantic City you establish that Barney was like an insane gambler.
还有，挺有意思的，我觉得是在大西洋城那一集，你设定了巴尼是个疯狂的赌徒。
And then you had to kind of go back and go, well, how did Barney become an insane gambler?
然后你不得不回过头去想，好吧，巴尼是怎么变成一个疯狂赌徒的？
A $1 dollar bet with Marshall at the Super Bowl.
因为在超级碗上和马歇尔打了一个一美元的赌。
God, that feels good.
天哪，感觉真好。
It's so sad.
太可悲了。
We see the beginning of a horrible addiction for Barney.
我们看到了巴尼可怕赌瘾的开端。
I know it's so great.
我知道，太棒了。
I also loved when Barney refuses to wear a suit to the funeral.
我还很喜欢巴尼拒绝穿西装去参加葬礼的那一段。
He shows up 100% almost mocking Ted with his style.
他出现的时候，简直是在用他的风格嘲讽泰德。
He's literally wearing a Ted Moseby outfit.
他穿的完全就是泰德·莫斯比的行头。
He barely has the hoodie under a jacket.
他甚至在夹克里穿了件连帽衫。
Like it's very Ted.
看起来非常泰德。
Yeah.
没错。
That's the one time you don't see it up.
那是你唯一一次没看到他穿西装。
I like, I really like Neil's read on that he's worried about the suit on the dead body.
我真的很喜欢尼尔对那段戏的演绎，他担心的是死者身上的那套西装。
The don't say it about it.
别提那个了。
It's so, it must be so scared.
太，那一定很吓人。
The suit, the suit scared of the dead guy.
西装，西装怕那个死人。
They're so heartless in that whole funeral scene.
他们在整个葬礼场景里真是太冷酷无情了。
No, it sure is like for a show that was so heart forward and people really tending to each other.
不，对于一部如此重感情、人们总是互相照顾的剧来说，这确实很奇怪。
and it really was like they weren't suddenly turned in the side fell cast.
而且他们并没有突然变成《宋飞正传》里的角色。
That's exactly what I didn't know the guy.
那正是我不知道那个人是谁的原因。
I'm sorry, I don't know.
抱歉，我不知道。
I'll go the other side.
我会去另一边。
They didn't know him.
他们不认识他。
Mr. I directed the best episode.
先生，我执导了最好的一集。
I apologize for any even a hint of a criticism.
我为任何哪怕一丝一毫的批评表示歉意。
And that by the way, that sounded like you.
顺便说一句，那听起来很像你。
I think I was Andrew McGowan.
我觉得我是安德鲁·麦高文。
I think that was you doing doing it with Rob.
我觉得那是你和罗伯一起演的。
What are your what other thoughts do we have?
你还有什么其他想法吗？
Do we have left?
我们还剩下什么？
how do we, what have we not gotten to about your memories of directing?
我们还有关于你执导记忆的什么没聊到？
I guess the best one.
我想是最好的一集吧。
I know that when you head on your, what is it called?
我知道当你前往你的，那叫什么来着？
The, when you head on your contraption and you're in the bar?
那个，当你前往你的装置，然后你在酒吧里的时候？
Yeah.
对。
I believe.
我想是吧。
Why am I the only one who remembers that?
为什么只有我一个人记得那个？
He's on and he goes by the waitress and he sees the cleavage and goes on and then goes back for a second look.
他走过去，经过女服务员身边，看到了乳沟，然后继续走，接着又回头看了一眼。
That was a green version.
那是绿色版本。
100% of Craig Thomas on set.
百分之百是克雷格·托马斯在片场。
Oh my God, really?
天哪，真的吗？
Yes.
是的。
I was just throwing you on the bus, man.
我当时只是把你推出去背锅，伙计。
You can't do that anymore, but 100% crinkles.
你现在不能那样做了，但百分之百是皱褶。
What if he goes back a second time?
如果他回头看第二次会怎样？
Was that all right?
那样可以吗？
That's a great idea.
那是个好主意。
It's almost like a shot from airplane when the boobs just come in.
这几乎就像《空前绝后满天飞》里的一个镜头，当胸部突然出现的时候。
It's definitely an airplane.
那绝对是《空前绝后满天飞》。
And then just leave.
然后就那样离开。
It is so airplane.
这太《空前绝后满天飞》了。
Oh my God.
天哪。
I think I did add Josh crossing by on Neil when he's yelling on the sidewalk.
我想我确实加了乔什在尼尔在人行道上大喊大叫时走过的镜头。
Oh, that made me laugh.
哦，那让我笑了。
I really liked that.
我真的很喜欢那个。
That made me laugh so hard.
那让我笑得好厉害。
I forgot about it.
我把它忘了。
Very funny.
非常有趣。
that's when they can in the connection the connective P the transition pieces pushing on the TV in the bar and then we're in the newsroom on that shot like and the walk through the way those stories all connected that was also very well done as much as it pains me to compliment you Rob but you know what's funny Rob so like years later I so appreciate that shot so so Neil's on the ground screaming and then Ted walks by with the sensory defritter 3000 kind of feeling around New York City about to bump into a lamppost.
那就是当他们在连接处，连接的P，过渡片段，在酒吧里推着电视，然后我们在那个镜头里进入新闻编辑室，那种走过的方式，那些故事是如何连接在一起的，那也做得非常好，尽管恭维你让我很痛苦，罗伯，但你知道什么很有趣吗，罗伯，多年后我非常欣赏那个镜头，所以尼尔在地上尖叫，然后泰德带着感官剥夺器3000走过，在纽约市四处摸索，差点撞到灯柱。
You were very funny in that.
你在那里面非常有趣。
So I was probably not, you're right, I probably on Monday was not written in.
所以我可能没有，你是对的，我周一可能没有被写进去。
By Wednesday, that's written in.
到了周三，那才被写进去。
But what people don't understand is moving the whole crew down to New York Street was a real process.
但人们不明白的是，把整个剧组搬到纽约街头是一个真正的过程。
You had a whole, you know, you're shooting down there, it's off the stage.
你有一整套，你知道，你在那里拍摄，是在舞台之外。
I had to come in and get, go through, you know, but, you know, I probably wasn't scheduled to work that day, but then I had to come in just to walk through in the background, which was the right narrative move and you laugh about it years later, but there's probably a part of you as an actor, you're like, I gotta come in on Thursday, I feel like I thought I was gonna go.
我不得不进来，穿过，你知道，但是，你知道，我那天可能没有被安排工作，但我不得不进来只是为了在背景中走过，这是正确的叙事举动，多年后你对此一笑置之，但作为演员，你内心可能有一部分会想，我周四得过来，我觉得我以为我要走了。
This is why you, I don't think you were so quiet about it.
这就是为什么你，我不认为你对此那么安静。
That is your strongest memories by protesting.
那是你最强烈的记忆，通过抗议。
He said, I'm not, if I'm doing this, I'm gonna do it in the fucking hands.
他说，我不，如果我要做这个，我要在操蛋的手里做。
That's really funny.
那真的很有趣。
I just heard that guy, that's funny.
我刚听到那个人说，那很有趣。
And the other side of it, He had to direct the camera guy because he did a lot of work and he had a look over it like you know If it's too jerky or two, so that was you're gonna.
而在另一面，他不得不指导摄像师，因为他做了很多工作，他不得不看一眼，就像你知道的，如果太颠簸或者太，所以那是你要做的。
Let me shoot it Then you could have been your hands your hands.
让我来拍，然后那可能是你的手，你的手。
Yeah.
对。
Well the century depravator stuff POV stuff That's that was very cool.
嗯，感官剥夺器的东西，POV的东西，那非常酷。
We're that come from Craig.
那是从哪里来的，克雷格。
Where'd that come from the room?
那是从哪里来的，房间里？
Do you remember?
你记得吗？
It might have been it might have been me I don't know it might have that might have been like we wanted Ted's approach to be endearing Lee over thought dorky and somewhat but inventively architecty.
可能是我，我不知道，可能那可能是我们想要泰德的方法变得讨人喜欢地过度思考、书呆子气，并且在某种程度上，但创造性地具有建筑师风格。
Did Cap and Crunch give us any money?
船长脆脆麦片给我们钱了吗？
Was that sponsored content or no?
那是赞助内容还是没有？
Sadly no, we missed a bet there.
遗憾的是没有，我们错失了一个机会。
But they could sponsor the podcast we're plugging in here on the podcast.
但他们可以赞助我们在播客里插入的这个播客。
They're still there, literally.
他们还在那里，字面意思上。
We don't have to call it a day, yeah.
我们不必收工，对。
But that stuff must have been fun to shoot with the cameraman.
但那些东西和摄影师一起拍一定很有趣。
There was a lot of camera acting in this episode, right?
这一集里有很多摄像机表演，对吧？
There was a lot of the camera was the joke for a lot of stuff in this episode.
这一集里有很多摄像机本身就是笑话的东西。
It was a fun one to do.
这是一个很有趣的拍摄。
You got to have fun.
你得玩得开心。
We handed you gold, Rob.
我们给了你金子，罗伯。
You handed you gold.
你给了你金子。
Oh, just get out of the way.
哦，只是别挡路。
Don't screw it up.
别搞砸了。
Yeah.
对。
You know what else I liked is Ted missing the bartender's fist at the lab when he goes back to the sauce?
你知道我还喜欢什么吗，泰德在回到酱汁时错过了酒保的拳头。
He has a proper depth present.
他有适当的深度感知。
He doesn't fully see the fist.
他没有完全看到拳头。
Yeah.
对。
I mean, sometimes, you know, we've talked, Rob, like sometimes I had to be the kind of virtuous center of the show or the romantic hero.
我的意思是，有时，你知道，我们谈过，罗伯，就像有时我不得不成为那种剧中道德高尚的中心或浪漫英雄。
But there was something fun those episodes where I just get to be as big an idiot as everyone else.
但那些剧集里有一些有趣的东西，我可以像其他人一样做一个大白痴。
Yeah.
对。
And this is definitely like Ted's as big an idiot as everyone else in this episode.
而这一集绝对就像泰德和这一集里的其他人一样是个大白痴。
He might be the biggest, yeah.
他可能是最大的，对。
The idiocy was his idea.
白痴行为是他的主意。
He is the absolute showrunner of idiocy on this one.
他是这一集里绝对的白痴行为统筹。
Right.
对。
Which I love.
我喜欢这一点。
I love that speed for Ted.
我喜欢泰德的那种速度。
I think it was very important to sometimes see that side of Ted because it earns you the more earnest sincere parts later.
我认为有时看到泰德的那一面非常重要，因为它为你后来更真诚、更诚恳的部分赢得了回报。
You need to know he's obsessed and he's gonna make the sensory decor 5,000 to care about him when he's gonna give a romantic speech.
你需要知道他很痴迷，他会制造感官剥夺器5000来关心他，当他要发表浪漫演讲时。
and that he can he can hang with the gang in their in their weirdness like he's not and they listen to him yeah and you think he would wear it only when he got got to the bar and went inside but no he wears it on a street he also wears it up the staircase of his own apartment of the building and he was a barman wearing it in the apartment as a guy that's a little bit of a buy-to but it was funny it was a good Barney reveal Barney sneaking out um well it was a great one Rob You nailed it.
而且他可以和帮派一起沉浸在他们的怪异中，就像他不是，他们听他的，对，你以为他只有在到了酒吧进去后才会戴上，但没有，他在街上戴着它，他还在自己公寓楼的楼梯上戴着它，他是一个在公寓里戴着它的酒保，作为一个有点买入的人，但这很有趣，这是一个很好的巴尼揭秘，巴尼溜出去，嗯，这是一个很棒的，罗伯，你做到了。
We'll give it to you.
我们会把它给你。
All I did was get handed great actors and a great script.
我所做的只是被交给了伟大的演员和伟大的剧本。
So there you go.
所以就是这样。
Well directed.
导演得很好。
Well done, my friend.
干得好，我的朋友。
It was the perfect amount of Jewish this episode.
这一集有完美的犹太感。
I just had a season one Rob Greenberg memory come rushing back to me that I would like to share until we got into when did we get into like the dressing rooms in the building behind the stage that was like season three.
我刚刚有一个第一季罗伯·格林伯格的记忆涌上心头，我想分享一下，直到我们进入，我们什么时候进入舞台后面大楼里的更衣室，那就像第三季。
I think so.
我想是吧。
Yeah.
对。
So for the first two seasons, we had these trailers out in front of the and I emerged from my trailer and I think the first two seasons I had a bit of a not quite a scowl on my face but I was overly kind of thoughtful and I couldn't I couldn't lighten up my face but I remember leaving my trailer one day and I walked out and I see Rob across the way and he said smile your life is going so much better than you ever thought it would.
所以前两季，我们在前面有这些拖车，我从我的拖车里出来，我想前两季我脸上有点，不完全是愁容，但我过于深思熟虑，我无法让我的脸轻松下来，但我记得有一天离开我的拖车，我走出来，看到对面的罗伯，他说，笑一笑，你的生活比你想象的要好得多。
That's an amazing thing to just have prepared to say around in the moment.
那是一件很棒的事情，可以在那一刻准备好说出来。
It was true.
那是真的。
It was longer than two weeks, but thank you, Rob.
那比两周长，但谢谢你，罗伯。
I did need someone to lighten me up and you were always you were always there for that.
我确实需要有人让我轻松下来，而你总是，你总是为此在那里。
So you were you were always good at that for all of us including me and Carter when we were the youngins, not knowing what we're doing.
所以你，你总是对我们所有人，包括我和卡特，当我们是年轻人，不知道自己在做什么时，都很擅长这一点。
Well, I think there was, what I was trying to say earlier was, you always reminded me that this was a great gig, like, like there's so many other harder ways to make a living than what we were doing.
嗯，我想有，我刚才想说的是，你总是提醒我这是一份很棒的工作，就像，就像有那么多比我们正在做的更难的谋生方式。
And you were like a walking reminder of that.
而你就像一个行走的提醒。
So thank you.
所以谢谢你。
You're welcome.
不客气。
And we knew we did, we knew we had a good one when we would pitch a bit in the room and Rob would say, yes, that's the green birdie and yes, give us one, Rob, we've, we've, we have to earn it.
我们知道我们做到了，当我们提出一个点子，罗伯说“没错，这就是那个‘绿鸟’（green birdie），没错，再给我们来一个”，罗伯，我们必须得赢得它。
at the urn.
在骨灰瓮旁。
You directed the best episode.
你执导了最棒的一集。
I'm not a wind up monkey.
我可不是什么上发条的猴子。
You directed the best episode of How I Met Your Mother.
你执导了《老爸老妈浪漫史》最棒的一集。
That is what I hear.
我听到的就是这么说的。
Oh, come on.
噢，得了吧。
You're really not going to give it up.
你真的不打算放弃这个话题吗。
Yes, all right.
好吧，行。
Okay.
好的。
Well, we like to end most of these episodes with a written letter.
我们喜欢以一封书信来结束大多数剧集。
We open often with a recorded letter.
我们通常以一封录音信件开场。
But today we're ending with It's a beautiful, wonderful letter that we received.
但今天我们要以一封信结束，这是一封我们收到的美丽而精彩的信。
If you would like to write us or leave us a voice note, possibly, hopefully to be read on the show, please go to howwemadeyourmother.com, H-W-M-Y-M.com.
如果您想给我们写信或留下语音留言，或许、希望能在节目中读出来，请访问 howwemadeyourmother.com，即 H-W-M-Y-M.com。
And wedding proposals are now accepted.
现在也接受求婚了。
Wedding proposals are now accepted, is where most people are going to propose marriage these days.
现在接受求婚了，这是如今大多数人打算求婚的地方。
And go to contact and follow the instructions.
点击“联系我们”并按照说明操作即可。
It should be pretty clear.
应该很清楚。
But we love hearing from people what the show meant to you and any other things you want to share with us about the show and how it's affected your life.
我们很喜欢听大家分享这部剧对你们的意义，以及你们想与我们分享的关于这部剧以及它如何影响了你们生活的任何事情。
Anyway, here is a letter this is from Alex.
总之，这是一封来自亚历克斯的信。
Dear Josh Craig and Alec, I hope this message finds you well.
亲爱的乔什、克雷格和亚历克，希望你们一切都好。
My name is Alex, writing from far away the Balkan Peninsula in Serbia.
我叫亚历克斯，从遥远的巴尔干半岛塞尔维亚写信给你们。
Here most people I know watched him in high school back when seasons four and five were airing.
在这里，我认识的大多数人都是在高中时看这部剧的，那时第四季和第五季正在播出。
I somehow missed that wave.
我不知怎么错过了那波热潮。
I didn't begin watching the show until I was at university around 2013 to 2014, but the moment I did, I was completely hooked.
直到2013到2014年上大学时我才开始看这部剧，但从那一刻起，我就彻底迷上了。
Since then, for the past 12 years, the show has been a quiet companion in my life.
从那时起的过去12年里，这部剧一直是我生活中安静的伴侣。
I've re-watched it many times, especially in the early days of COVID when I was 27, the same age as the characters in those early seasons.
我重温过很多次，尤其是在新冠疫情初期，当时我27岁，和剧中前几季角色的年龄一样。
Now, in my early 30s, re-watching the show again feels different yet equally powerful.
现在我30出头，再次重温这部剧感觉不同，但同样充满力量。
When I was younger, it was the love story that struck me.
年轻时，打动我的是爱情故事。
And now it's the whole worldview of the show, the friendships, the searching, the heartbreak, the growing up, the strange mix of melancholy and joy that adulthood brings.
而现在，是整部剧的世界观、友谊、探索、心碎、成长，以及成年生活带来的那种忧郁与快乐的奇妙混合。
There's an honesty in it that only grows with age.
其中有一种随着年龄增长而愈发深刻的诚实。
And now with some distance, I also realize how much I miss the world the show portrays.
现在回过头来看，我也意识到我有多么怀念这部剧所描绘的世界。
A few days ago, I re-watched the episode where the gang gets smartphones for the first time, and from today's perspective, it already feels like a classic, a little time capsule in a world that is slipping away.
几天前，我重温了那集大家第一次用上智能手机的剧集，从今天的角度来看，它已经感觉像是一部经典，是一个正在消逝的世界里的小小时间胶囊。
Originally I discovered Josh's music, unfortunately only last year, it's never too late.
最初我发现乔什的音乐，遗憾的是直到去年才发现，不过永远都不晚。
As someone who has been making music for a large part of my life, that immediately struck a chord in me.
作为一个大半辈子都在创作音乐的人，这立刻引起了我的共鸣。
For the first time, I thought maybe I should also try to sing.
我第一次想，也许我也应该尝试唱歌。
And so as a small homage to the show, I wrote two songs inspired by himium, something completely and utterly different from the music that I usually write and record.
所以作为对这部剧的一点致敬，我写了两首受《老爸老妈浪漫史》启发的歌，这和我平时创作和录制的音乐完全不同。
Thank you for creating something so heartfelt, funny, human, and enduring.
感谢你们创造了如此真诚、有趣、人性化且经久不衰的作品。
has influenced more of my life than I ever expected a television show could.
它对我的生活产生的影响超出了我对一部电视剧的预期。
I would have a million in one questions, but I will let you guys answer each and every one of them weekly in your amazing podcast.
我有一百万个问题，但我会让你们在每周精彩的播客中一一回答。
Wow.
哇。
Thank you so much, Alex.
非常感谢你，亚历克斯。
What a great letter.
多棒的一封信啊。
That was lovely.
太可爱了。
That was lovely and kind of linked up with what we were talking about, about the lost world of actually spending time with each other and we're on screens, which ironically we are doing right now, spending time with each other on screen to talk about.
这太可爱了，而且和我们刚才讨论的内容联系在一起，关于那种真正花时间陪伴彼此的失落世界，而我们现在却在屏幕上，讽刺的是我们现在也正在这样做，在屏幕上花时间陪伴彼此来谈论这个。
Thank you, Alex.
谢谢你，亚历克斯。
I'm so glad people in Serbia love the show.
我很高兴塞尔维亚的人们喜欢这部剧。
It's thrilling to hear the geographic reach of the show.
听到这部剧的地理覆盖范围真是令人激动。
And Rob Greenberg, we're delighted to see you and to be able to chat with you about this episode.
罗伯·格林伯格，很高兴见到你，并能和你聊聊这一集。
And please let me know when you're in New York.
请务必告诉我你什么时候来纽约。
I will let you know it's a pleasure.
我会告诉你的，这是我的荣幸。
It's lovely to see your faces.
见到你们真好。
We'll have you back.
我们会再邀请你来的。
Thank you for having me.
谢谢你们邀请我。
It's hard for me to think of how I met your mother without you as a huge part of it.
如果没有你作为其中重要的一部分，我很难想象《老爸老妈浪漫史》。
And I'm so glad you were there that first day where I met everyone that changed my life.
我很高兴你在我见到改变我人生的每个人的第一天就在那里。
And yeah, come back to me.
是的，再来找我吧。
The earliest believer in it in so many ways, Rob.
罗伯，你在很多方面都是最早的信徒。
You really were still there for me and Carter when we were in over our heads.
当我们不知所措时，你真的还在那里支持我和卡特。
And I don't think the show would have been the same without you helping preserve it, what was special about it to begin with.
我不认为如果没有你帮助保留它最初的特别之处，这部剧会是现在的样子。
So thank you, we love you.
所以谢谢你，我们爱你。
Ladies and gentlemen, Rob Greenberg.
女士们先生们，罗伯·格林伯格。
Thank you and I love you both.
谢谢你们，我也爱你们俩。
So Alex, who wrote us this wonderful letter that we just read, he sent us in one of those two songs that he wrote that was inspired by how I met your mother and we're going to send you off with this one.
所以亚历克斯，写了这封我们刚刚读到的精彩信件的人，他寄来了他写的两首歌中的一首，灵感来自《老爸老妈浪漫史》，我们要用这首歌来送别大家。
So here is that wonderful song.
这就是那首美妙的歌。
Thanks Alex for sending it in.
感谢亚历克斯寄来这首歌。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas and is presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
《How we made your mother》由乔什·拉德诺和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任执行制片人，由 Office Ladies Network 和 Odyssey 呈现和发行。
This episode is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
本集也由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛担任执行制片人。
The show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matata.
节目由我，亚历克·莱夫制作和剪辑，我们的联合制片人是道格·马塔塔。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的亚历克斯·里夫斯。
Our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
我们的数字内容制作人，也就是 Z 世代大师，是艾米丽·布伦伯格。
Artwork by John Morrow.
艺术设计由约翰·莫罗负责。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple Podcasts 或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论本节目。
It really does help the show.
这真的对节目很有帮助。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是《New York City》，由我们自己的乔什·拉德诺创作，克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马尤斯基提供了额外的音乐。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢萝拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajormother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
访问 HowWeMajormother.com 了解更多信息，并点击联系页面给我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
你们的故事和问题是节目中重要的一部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at JoshRadner.com.
在 Substack 上订阅乔什·拉德诺的时事通讯，并在 JoshRadner.com 查看他的音乐和其他一切。
After Craig Thomas' debut novel, that's not how it happened, wherever books are sold, and check out his other published writings at CraigThomasWriter.com.
购买克雷格·托马斯的处女作小说《That's Not How It Happened》，各大书店均有销售，并在 CraigThomasWriter.com 查看他发表的其他作品。
And you can subscribe to my own Dead Fathers Society, also on Substack.
你也可以在 Substack 上订阅我自己的《Dead Fathers Society》。
To learn more about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign, to raise money for congenital pediatric heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解更多关于如何做出改变的信息，即本节目为先天性儿科心脏病研究筹款的持续活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“Make a Difference”标签。
will, in fact, dance.
确实会跳舞。